welcome to the heaven podcast it seems
like it's been a decade since we last
talked to you guys like weird song
before we start recording and Kalin
insisted that it needed to continue into
the podcast so Kailyn there's a debate
okay a raging debate not really raging
but when does a decade start is is is
now the new decade or is 2021 the start
of the new day ahead because I am like
an even number biased person I think it
should start starting so the zero yeah
cuz like 1990 is that the 90s the decade
starts with the zero I looked it up do
you know why everyone like some people
say that the the next decade doesn't
start until like the year after why
there was no zero and are like calendar
that were like following now for some
reason it was like one BC and then the
next year was 180 so they started at one
start about what I'm sorry
that's like saying I'm going to consume
a cup of milk but I will start at one
and when I consumed that cup now I am it
- even though I've only consumed one I
think that you know time is what we make
of it
time is everyone's time is a personal
experience right no one else is
experiencing your exact timeline even
know I was about to make a false
pronouncement about how each person
experience is time differently but time
is weird time is strange does not go
down there what we're gonna be watching
a lot of rhythm more
you guys you don't know Rick and Morty
there's a lot of parallel universes
there's a lot of like time travel and
portals and continuity and oh it's it's
it's confusing contemplating like what
version of like the multiverse the
universe and time continuity makes the
most sense because no one knows it's
very confusing they're all guesses but
today there are no guesses about why
we're gonna be talking about because
we're gonna be talking about resolutions
in general and what we think about
resolutions we're gonna be talking about
past resolutions future as Aleutians
2020 resolutions for work and personal
life so so we're gonna be getting into
all of that because I think it is good
every now and then to reflect on the
past and plan for the future
responsible yeah I think that Kalyn and
I both really like making goals it's
interesting I like making goals but I
also have never really been one to get
caught up in like resolutions that bad I
think is a good point one thing that I
don't get caught up in is the time scale
of the resolution it's like I like to
choose a direction to move in but
sometimes setting time goals can't be
good and sometimes they can be bad it
really just depends on the goal like for
us launching our channel we chose like a
kind of specific date after a while of
like you know figuring out like what a
reasonable date is and then we stuck to
that because otherwise we might have put
it off indefinitely so some things are
good to choose dates for but other
things it's it's really stressful and
sometimes counterproductive for certain
people to set dates because then it just
puts undue time pressure or just undue
pressure and it's like you're doing the
best you can that's the best you can and
just putting like an arbitrary like
countdown on it this vessel I think it
also kind of depends on what the goal is
- like how much control do you have over
the outcome of the goal because for
example if if you have a goal that I'm
going to reach a certain sub can't
that's kind of like there's only so much
you can do to actually control that yeah
but if your goal is like I'm gonna have
fun with my hair this year I don't know
you have control over that you do you
could chop it off if you feel like it oh
you can color it purple chop my hair off
it looks great I like it I think you and
I didn't really do it I want a hair
dresser yeah but not so much probably so
good I think that I'm just still trying
to figure out what I want to do with my
hair to a certain degree and like I just
keep on going to different places until
sometimes just like takes a guest that I
like I can't describe it I don't know
what I'm going for
[Laughter]
so let's let's look back at past goals
that we've had and 2017 as we start the
talk the the Channel in 2017 March of
2017 are you doing the math it's almost
three years that's crazy
mm-hmm when did we like first think
about starting the channel in at the end
of 2016
Wow cuz it was like we in the December
yeah cuz in like late fall or at late
summer early fall that's when we started
doing products mhm and we went through
our first like holiday season and you
know we were kind of on the product
train and we started to realize that if
we ever wanted that to become like its
own full-time business we have to start
hiring people and it wasn't like a big
production and we're like we don't want
to do that but we still want to make
stuff and we want to do it together
maybe we try YouTube mm-hmm so that was
like around the holidays I wonder when
we first created our very first like
filmed our first file like what was that
date was that in like January oh my gosh
it's been three years since we start
filming since we first started filming
we've been youtubers for three years now
yeah even though we didn't publish a
video yeah we started the process we
started the process yeah that's weird
yeah cuz we
a few months to make our first we took
we took like three months to make our
first five videos we were figuring a lot
and we weren't putting as much time into
it because we were doing it all and like
nice nice weekends and it stayed that
way for a while yeah wow that's crazy
three years of kind of doing this
process that's the longest job I've ever
had my longest was three years my past
job was three years I don't know how
long my past job was yeah a little bit
right we stood we've believed in
youtubers longer than we've been doing
anything else that is really weird and I
feel like we haven't been doing YouTube
very long maybe well it's very like well
I think it's like a millennial thing is
like we jump around from job to job
pretty frequently whereas the generation
before us like was more loyal to their
employer hope and we're like we put in
two or three years that's enough not so
guilty I think that everyone's doing
that more now well also there aren't
pension plans as much anymore they're on
unions as much yeah there's a time where
1 in 3 people working in the United
States was unionized and that is not the
case anymore
there are still a lot of unions a lot of
content creators in some ways are in
unions I mean actors aren't unions
actors aren't content creators I mean
they might be if they start a YouTube
channel but I think like if you're an
actor you're not a content creator
because the content creator is more big
picture like like full picture yeah
thank you if your answers aren't contact
critters in like a minor what yeah
you're right not unless they started you
can't start making their own content
yeah cuz they're there they're acting
employee yeah they're paid employees
emitters yeah that'd do a small part of
it well the entertainment industry has a
lot of guilds and unions and stuff like
that Screen Actors Guild and I know like
a lot of radio hosts and stuff like that
they're also part of unions like NPR a
lot of them are unionized and stuff I
wonder how long it's gonna be till there
is like a content creator Union there is
there's one charge oh no
there was an unofficial well I mean what
is official and what's unofficial like
what what government have to recognize
the Union for it to be official or is it
like I think that but it's just it's
just like a company a union is kind of a
company really it's it's just a
collective it's just like everyone and
and don't take my word for it but this
is my understanding this is my
understanding everyone disagrees to sign
up and like abide by the rules of the
Union they all pay in a small portion of
their salaries to pay for the Union and
and and and the Union like basically
unifies them and like if one person's
like I am dissatisfied with the working
conditions here become like the company
that employs Minh then was like so haha
leave them but if like 80% of the
workforce at a company is part of a
union and that whole Union goes to the
company says hey everyone in our group
has agreed if you don't change we're
gonna leave then that company is like
well I feel unlike I'm in trouble
because such a huge portion of the other
than my employees can just like what the
crazy thing is there's so many youtubers
have to be so it would have to be so big
that's almost what happened with the
alternative with vine you ever hear
about the negotiation between the bond
and like their top creators basically
the top creators didn't form a guild or
a union or anything like that they just
kind of like agreed hey let's all get
together and you know put our powers
together and make them pass make them
pass and they they asked for a lot of
money a lot of money and vines like guys
we're not making any money it's like
we're we're one of these bootstrapping
companies that just like gets loans from
all these big companies and we're just
bleeding out money like crazy III can't
pay you and then and then vine died so
that that's that's my understanding of
that story too
welcome to the evident Galen podcast the
podcast of disclaimers and New Year's
resolution don't talk about things you
don't know about we wouldn't talk about
anything I think that we were talking
about resolutions we are talking about
unions anyways okay so looking back so I
think we've covered 2017 you know we we
ace that goal
I'll start the channel our goal was to
start the channel and we started the
channel yeah kept it pretty like I mean
not that starting a channel is a small
feat but we we didn't really know we
were going into so we kept it pretty
open like just start hittin yeah and we
did that really well
looking back 2018 that's when we were
just like okay let's go to every event
let's do every collab that's just say
yes to everything and see what happens
that was our 2018 channel goal oh geez
that was a stressful time it was it was
like really fun I felt a lot more
connected in 2018
whereas I do feel in some ways slightly
more isolated in 2019 and it was kind of
out of necessity like 20 18 20 was was
very fun but so exhausting we we were
traveling one to two times every month
and in that travel we were either going
to an event usually one that we are
speaking at or doing a collab which is
like you know two videos two videos in
one week and it's always a lot of fun
cuz you're like staying at someone
else's house and like adventure
adventures and it's like a super fun
time but it's it's a lot of work and so
2018 was really fun but probably our
most stressful year yeah and 2019 are
our goals were more about like
diversifying and starting to like I
don't know kind of figure out our
overall internet portfolio well also and
18 we just wanted to grow we just wanted
to get all of the ideas into our head we
wanted to go talk to other chronic area
creators we wanted to go to these events
we wanted to like gather all of the
information and then the 2019 we
processed it I think in a way we're like
okay what type of changes do we want to
make internally and I think in 2019
that's when we made some of the biggest
most important changes in our channel
yeah I think you're right
because 2019 is really when we well not
just in their channel but I'm gonna talk
about like our overall everything else
when we started the podcast in the
gaming channel yeah which is a pretty
decent shift yeah and change in addition
but also it's when we finally like we
kind of been toying with the idea of
shifting our channel to be more
entertainment but it's when I feel like
we fully like like got in stride with
that idea you know it wasn't like an
overnight change but also what is
entertainment and to who you know
there's a lot it's like what what type
of entertainment do we want to make is I
think the main thing that he kind of
settled on because I think that you know
we were making more instructional
content but some people find you know
fine woodworking videos with not too
much talking to be entertaining in some
ways so it's like what type of
entertaining content did we want to make
what do we want to focus on what did we
want to highlight what did we want to
cut okay I'm afraid that then going from
like more DIY instructional stuff to
videos where the project was kind of the
excuse for the video but it was more
about just like casual experience yeah
with us while we like do stuff and leave
goofy parts and yeah and I think in 2019
we did have like the hope I'm not sure
if we ever really defined it as a goal
but to reach half a million subscribers
by 2019 we were just like we only
discussed it between the two of us
basically we didn't we don't know though
yeah we did that's awesome and crazy
yeah
and you know you know we kind of it's
it's strange the main reason why we had
that goal is because we looked at our
projections and I think we can do it
yeah our projections on socialblade like
if you if you go to social and it'll
have a guess so I guess it wasn't it
wasn't fully just like a goal that we
like pulled out of our heads it was a
reasonable goal cuz that was our
projections basically it's like we just
wanted to keep on growing at a healthy
rate because you know looking at our
projections if we got to half a million
by the end of the year we kept up a good
growth rate standard with what our
channel seems to be capable of and if we
got less then that means we had gotten
less healthy so I think that's kind of
why we we set that goal but I'm really
trying not to set any more goals for
2020 even though I kind of have a number
goals yeah yeah again it's kind of based
on like social brave blade projections
that tracks your past growth and it's
like you don't want to fall behind but I
don't know if that's the same as like a
resolution like that's more that's like
I'm liking more I love like like
performance objective performance
indicator goal yeah business side of
things but like that I don't know I
really know how important that is here
anyways like important to us are
important too important to us in some
ways because I mean I think that we're
gonna talk about it a little bit earlier
but this is the slowest period of video
releases we've ever had
we have really so few videos in the past
like few weeks like the period that
we're at right now
today is December has been kind of
purposefully slow it's the second yeah
so it's Thursday and tomorrow we're not
releasing a video which is gonna be a
like and we release on last Friday but
not the Friday before this is the very
first time ever we're doing a video no
video a video no video and then a video
again and we're gonna do three I think
in a row after this we're gonna try to
really get get the engines revving again
because we've kind of gotten past the
big build-up up to dues that have been
like so
as down but this is definitely an
experiment and slowing down a little bit
we're gonna see how much it hurts our
channel overall but I think like I'm
becoming more okay with that in a way
because like what are the alternatives
we keep up an unsustainable pace for too
long and then we suffer consequences so
I think that I think it's good that
we're continuing to pull back so I think
that my goal for 2020 is to establish a
better balance like a work better better
work-life balance and like find out how
many videos we can do per month that
that is a sustainable pace because you
know especially on the end of 2019 we it
was an unsustainable pace for probably a
month or two months or maybe even more
they got us into that situation and we
were falling behind on too much so it's
like we were doing too many videos I
know that for sure what is the right
balance will probably be shifting back
and forth and we'll just find it just
through experimentation mm-hmm so I
think that's my main main goal for 2020
what about you yeah I mean that's a big
one better work/life balance I do think
a big part of that or the the biggest
factor that we have control over that
determines how much work we're doing is
the amount of videos we do per month so
that's why I like we experienced it a
little bit with pulling back some in
December to kind of test things out it's
gonna be hard to like test or see the
outcome of that until we've done it for
a few months hitting another 2020 goal
is like I'm really excited about the
gaming too oh my gosh me too
not that I'm not excited about our main
channel you know I've always been
excited about our main channel but yeah
my family was asking me just the other
day you're like are you getting tired of
evident Kaelyn cuz all you talk about is
the gaming channel now it's like no no I
really love our main channel I'm a
channel it's amazing about like I'm so
excited by the gaming channel yeah yeah
it's it's it's like we we just look
forward to that so much and I think you
know it is because we're just hanging
out
video games I mean how is that not fun
yeah I think like it's I think one
reason we really like is cuz it still
feels like a break yeah you know when we
when we stream and we play games and I
know it's not everybody's thing not
everyone enjoys watching gaming videos
and even I don't really like I don't
watch other gaming videos we don't
either I don't either
me myself and myself like so it's not
something I ever first saw us doing
really mm-hmm just cuz it's not content
that I watch but I like making
entertaining and I like it's interesting
I like both of us like playing games but
we also like doing whatever we do when
we let that what while we play games
that people find entertaining I guess
but I like like like putting together
like a little bit of a show like using
like the stream deck and having sound
effects and transitions and like setting
up the right type of game and like like
it's kind of like a live performance
because it kind of it is a live
performance but it's not just like the
two of us sitting in front like right
here or at and just playing games
silently we are kind of putting on a
little bit of a show in some ways it's
fun
there's fun I didn't really ever it's
not like improv because it's not like
you're making things up but it's kind of
almost like a mix between playing games
and a live podcast and a little improv
and a little improv yeah yeah it is it's
it's very fun and an interesting thing
is our gaming channel cuz we're almost a
year in to the gaming channel yeah we
might be at about a year because we
started it I think in January
yeah or at least we started streaming
and like January yeah
and it's almost at the same size our
main channel was a year in and it's kind
of different to measure because like on
one hand I think it's a lot harder to
start a gaming channel because it's so
much more competitive than a maker
channel where like there's just not as
many people in the maker crowd yeah
gaming communities very crowded and very
competitive but on the other hand we
obviously had a head start because we
had an audience we could launch to but
at the same time the amount of time that
we've been putting into the gaming
channel is like so much less than of
what we put into our main channel or
less than about a sixth I'd say six
versus know maybe 1/10 between 1/10 and
1/6 of the time we're not editing them
all we're doing is like playing games
Rafi playing games for a few hours and
then you know dealing with some back-end
stuff some administrative stuff but
that's yeah it's not merely but I think
there is there is a little bit of like
rush of excitement in starting a new
channel I'm seeing it grow
oh yeah you know so I think that's like
part of the excitement too is it's you
know I think another thing that I've
really been liking and I'm I'm not fully
sure why I like it but I've really been
liking series like we're in the middle
of a main channel now oh yeah our main
channel yeah sorry so sorry for the main
channel I've really been liking series I
mean in the gaming channel we have game
series that's not really apply alright
so on the main channel we have series
right now we're recording another by
verse DIY a little sneak peek and and
it's fun knowing like like it's a box
that we've made ourselves and we can
leave the box whenever we want within
the series but it's kind of nice having
some definition to what we're making
because most most normal videos that
there's like the intro can be whatever
we want the outro can be whatever we
want the project can be whatever we want
everything can be whatever we want
that's a lot of decisions which can be
kind of it it can be a lot a lot of
decisions make so it's like if you know
I asked Kaelyn to draw a unicorn
stomping a house full of robots
yeah I can Java she could draw and she
would like
you know be able to start sooner she
would be able to like come up with our
own embellishments like what color are
things what like you know you can have
self so much creative freedom is the
unicorn happy is the unicorn sad what
are the robots are they robotic well
what shapes are they but you know you
can just start you can start doing that
right away whereas if I say hey can I
draw something fun and unique you'd be
like yeah like and like you know if you
think about that example it's like well
no anything but imagine like whatever
you're drawing is put on the internet
for everyone to judge then that like
draw something fun and unique you're
like yeah yeah but also it's like also
like it's almost oh I have a better
analogy it's like you've been sketching
stuff and putting it out there on the
internet and every time you do a drawing
yeah after like think of like the
character the design all the stuff and
it's like everything from scratch and
then you draw one thing that everyone
likes
it's the unicorn you know and and the
unicorn is in a battle with robots and
you're oh man they like that let's do
that again let's do the same unicorn
robots but in another circumstance now
the unicorns partying with the robots
yeah so it's like you can like use that
framework to do more yeah I don't know I
went down that analogy road of fun yeah
it is fun having a series and it's also
like in the videos that we watch online
we enjoy a series cuz like as a viewer
it's kind of nice knowing what to expect
in terms of like the structure of the
video maybe looking over to in a way cuz
unexpected stuff is bad but yeah you you
like look forward to certain parts so
like every gourmet makes Claire video
you know you you look forward to
different parts of it and different like
challenges and yeah and everything like
that and so I think that's another part
it's like as a viewer I like series so
I'm excited to make you as a creator and
this is the only other series we've kind
of started and it's not really a new
series or even really a series we just
thought like
the name yeah we just wanted to give it
a name because like in some ways well in
many ways like all the videos in this
quote-unquote series are connected but
it's the DIY Aires which is like our
home DIY Ruiz which is like our home DIY
projects because I feel like those are
very different than like a resin project
yeah you know because it's like us
fixing up our house and making over our
house but also there are some
reoccurring elements in those videos
that we can line up and order and we you
know once we figure out the best order
to do them in that make sense for that
type of video and we've been we've been
ordering those videos or we've been
structuring those videos in that way
since the laundry room makeover Wow
because we do a before tour talk about
the problems a Photoshop makeover where
we like talk about the plans and then we
get into it and then we have a room you
know we do the project than we have a
reveal but it's almost like we have to
come up with that formula almost from
scratch the same thing again it's like
you know you you kind of look back on it
but we never really formalized it until
we came up with a home DIY areas kind of
format even though it's not really so
much of a format so much of its still
free-flowing but having a little bit of
a box it's really nice yeah and makes it
feel more like a thing and in some ways
I feel like by having series it makes me
feel less weird about like some videos
seeming random it's like if someone if
someone pops into our Channel and
they're they see like okay they did a a
gaming treadmill task oh they did resin
black hole table they have like these
kind of okay my eyes are going people
are like oh they do these like kind of
artistic furniture like art slash
furniture kind of project yeah and then
it's like oh they're their own home
improvement refinishing their patio yeah
that's like more random I feel like
having it be its own series kind of
acknowledges the fact that we
no it's different yeah I don't know yeah
I think it really makes sense makes a
lot of sense one thing we've done every
year and we kind of knew that we are
going to be doing this but we kind of
keep on pushing our content strategy
every year it's been very different we
started out with a easy value
proposition hey we're gonna show you how
to do something here's a DIY video
instruction and the quickest amount of
time possible to get through the steps
yeah Walter I'm a little bit of
personality in there here and there like
a four minute video on how to do okay
when I watch our old videos they're so
fast I was like what the heck is so fast
so we started out there and then we
started going from just very functional
ones to more fun projects and then from
there we went into entertaining more
entertaining content and longer videos
and stuff what do you think's gonna hold
what do you think we're gonna do in 2020
in terms of our content are we going to
shift it anymore have we kind of found a
nice equilibrium I don't know I think we
found a pretty good equilibrium in terms
of like focus on the project itself
versus focus on like banter yeah I think
if you're doing a project you you have
to still keep there's a certain minimum
amount of like project stuff yeah then
otherwise is the viewer like they just
especially with things like woodworking
like and if you're not a woodworker it
it can kind of feel like you show a
minimum amount and whatever that make
sense to follow on yeah so I feel like
our balance there is pretty good I do
think I would like to and this is me
personally I would like to continue to
push the bounds project wise a little
bit but probably keep a similar ratio of
like yeah project focus versus like
banter and just like knowing when to
montage knowing when to do the mass at
clap to this like moving this along and
stuff like that well that's that's part
of yeah yeah
all of that yeah well that's part of
like the balance you have like not
getting too into the weeds on the
project steps yeah but so pushing the
bounds of what that project is though I
kind of want to continue that we started
that in 2019 with incorporating some art
projects like or I guess maybe it was
late 2018 is when we did our first
acrylic pores oh yeah and so that was
kind of the first one where it was like
oh this is just kind of like art yeah
you know I mean we've done an art
project when we first out of the channel
but after the acrylic pores and we did
like a bob ross then we did some more
like we did the spin art we did another
bob ross we did the pendulum painting
and so I want to continue to expand on
the art path because I really like doing
fun art projects I could also see us
expanding on like the science adjacent
part I also want expand on the science
adjacent and like fun little sort of
experiments and then we can still
incorporate making into it like we can
make the thing we're testing or you know
I like a lot of science adjacent stuff
involves making so I think that it is it
does mesh well yeah but I think like one
thing I wanted to build I just want to
have this and it's it's so dumb it
doesn't make any sense we don't need it
I just want it remember in Mythbusters
you know those blast shields they had
blast shields and I want some excuse to
make blast shields
well the excuse is blowing something up
but we also live in a residential
neighborhood I don't know either but I
wanted blast shields yeah sometime in
our future maybe it's when we moved to
like another place or who knows I don't
know but at some point I want blast
shields and I wanted some reason to have
blast shields basically probably remote
controlled explosions yes so just
letting you know that that's in your
future
at some point in your future thank you
no I do you think I do you think more
like science adjacent type stuff would
be fine
or also even like cooking adjacent type
stuff mmm this this cuz some of that is
kind of sciency like one thing I really
want to try to do is man I feel like I
just reference gourmet makes all the
time but I want to try making like taffy
taffy yeah it's like science and it's
squishy it's like slime you can eat
basically you know it's would we make it
in the workshop
in the workshop with like a hot plate
yeah cuz that's worth waiting yeah
no any cooking adjacent stuff we would
do in the workshop but like I feel like
that's pretty close to like so there's I
think there's more making in like making
taffy than there is in making soap would
you have to make something out of the
taffy you would have to like know you
pour it in molds and then construct
something with it or like no it's just
just evident Caleb make taffy well we
didn't make soap molds I guess maybe
they make taffy molds I don't know I
feel like we need to have like that that
thing that that pizzazz that like maybe
it's a really interesting flavor but
taffy is just wait a vu toffee candy
flavored javi can be flavoring yeah I
was thinking of caramel
oh no caramel is easy caramel is just
sugar and butter and other things
anyways we're getting off into the weeds
yeah but but I feel like we could come
up with some sort of cooking related
thing yeah and it would have to have
like some kind of twist I don't know
maybe like making the world's largest
taffy ball I mean maybe not the world's
largest making it's happy balls but oh
oh oh oh I know what it is you can tell
me I'll tell you but not not not my
family
this is he great
I don't think taffy works that way oh it
doesn't oh it doesn't like Phil I don't
think it'll fill out details Oh what
have we here down then you're gonna mess
with the chemical structure see it's
complicated okay entertaining told me we
can we can do it or we can say like okay
this is the video can you use silicone
molds with taffy you could do with
caramel yeah Karl's not happy but what
about my idea with caramel daddy oh my
gosh do we eat it Oh that'd be an idea
that's an idea it's an idea oh the
people thing currently have no idea that
so it would pour would make candy shaped
objects that would make objects out of
candy that are interesting shapes good
good explanation Evan okay moving on
personal resolutions do you have any
personal resolutions
so are we gonna be basic people wouldn't
you use the same resolution that
everyone has workout more I mean I mean
I do I do I would like to workout I
would like to work it's hard to split
off personal resolutions because like
everything is tied to time and time is
all dependent on business stuff which is
one of the reasons why one of our
resolutions is better work-life hahah
like it'd be nice to take a few weekends
and 20 time that would be nice yeah we
took off like most of the day for both
of our birthdays this in 2019 that's
great we took it pretty much a whole day
off twice for each of our birthdays and
it was great and each of our Christmases
we did Christmas with your family and
Christmas with my family oh yeah oh yeah
hope everyone had a very Merry Christmas
yeah Wow gosh darnit gosh we should have
led with that
yeah those embedded for those of you
guys who like listen beyond the intro
thank you yeah we got sick reason why
cuz there we were gonna do a video this
week BAM
both getting sick and Southers no no no
no no no it was actually like I feel
weird saying this but being sick gave us
an excuse to just chill I worked oddly
well with my parents yeah the only
minimally worked yeah when we got home
we still worked but we could do it at a
slower pace because we weren't feeling
great yeah it's like every day like
often I'm not gonna say every day I kind
of feel this but often times at the end
of the day I feel like I didn't do
enough yes because the list is so big
yeah and we have so much to do and seems
like we just take a small chunk out of
it every time you're sick it's like I
mean you do feels like bonus so maybe we
can kind of keep some of that mentality
well the only like the only way we can
keep
if we reduce the amount of stuff we have
to do and the only reason why we were
able to like have that relaxed attitude
is because we canceled the whole video
we canceled whole week's worth of work
and we're like wow we're doing good so
much stuff like a week's worth of time
yeah one other thing though I did raise
my hand a personal resolution one thing
that we thought of is like man during
that crazy period where we were working
so hard we we can't we put out some
really good videos that was when cat
kiss that was when catio that was like
we just we just like no anyways we made
a few really good videos our channel was
really healthy and like everything was
growing so well but we were so
overworked we didn't have any time for
anything during that time and then the
period afterwards our channel our videos
didn't do as well on our channel wasn't
as healthy and I was kind of we were
kind of thinking about like the balance
of that and one thought that I had is
that during the crazy period during the
period we were just working all the time
we didn't have enough time to put
towards ideas and revising them again
and again and again and we didn't have
time to like maintain all the things
that set us up to have that really good
month so it's like also we are pretty
exhausted so we purposely in December
which is like our recovery month we
picked videos that were like a little
bit easier yeah a little bit easier and
then and we just didn't have time to
like fully refine the ideas yeah so it's
like it's kind of like if you put
yourself in this situation we were
working so hard you don't have the time
to really put to revise and brainstorm a
whole bunch then it's like was it even
worth it like then then you're just
gonna put yourself in a cycle of life
always being the rollercoaster you know
where if you like spread things out a
little bit more and put more time
towards developing ideas towards brain
storming towards iterating and
everything towards research and
development and stuff then I think the
overall channel health would be better
and more consistent it would certainly
be less emotionally exhausting so I
think that wasn't one of the things I
really want to do in 2020 is not put
ourselves again it's that once we have
that better work/life balance once we
have the better time balance put some of
that time towards like working on ideas
even more than they already do even
though we will put a lot of time into it
just put even more time into it yeah
yeah yeah
I do think that would be cool um and it
is interesting because even though like
YouTube is kind of a numbers game where
it's like on one hand the more videos
you do the more chances something's
gonna take off at the same time it's
like most of our growth in any chunk of
time is because of one or two videos you
know the ones that really go a couple
really go and they bring everything else
along with them and once they die down
then like growth kind of dies down and
so it's like if it would be better for
our subscriber to have more or like less
videos total but more of them that
really go instead of just churning out
more that just kind of get that standard
amount of views all the balance it's all
a balancing act you know yeah do you
have any um so we kind of started on
personal resolutions that we didn't
really like stick with that secret
anymore personal resolutions you have I
think so one is and I guess this
technically could be tied to work again
because we used videos as an excuse in
the past to do this but when I get the
house more organized we still have at
least one junk room at any given time we
just like we mentioned before we often
have to like figure out some of the junk
depending on what area of the house
we're working on I feel like throughout
the year we've simultaneously and so our
garage has stayed pretty nice at the
garage estate because that's like
priority yeah because we have to work in
it yeah I think I think overall
everything is better um but I do want to
like fully finish
tackling things so that there's my I
mean my dream is that there is no junk
room you know what I mean and maybe
there's like a junk shelf or a junk
counter and it's reduced to that because
I know there's always gonna be like oh
we had to buy stuff early for a project
and we don't need it yet and there's
nowhere to put it and it's just here and
I like accept that yeah and I'm fine
with that I know you know something
we've joked about like if we ever get
like a bigger house just having like a
warehouse room like a processing like a
like an inventory processing like in
project or in process staging area
because like our house is a house and
it's a production studio it's like yeah
a workshop and it works off so yeah so
yeah I mean I do think that would be
really cool and I I know that some of
that we do have to have but I feel like
we can continue to reduce the junk room
I think stuff so that's a goal it's so
funny we were just watching this apphia
video a little bit ago with lunch and
she has like a whole like multiple rooms
for like storage and staging and all the
stuff that's crazy
Sofia my guard for those of you who who
haven't watched a lot of YouTube like us
I think that one other thing I want to
add to that
like like take care of the junk room and
make the office a little bit better I
would so much time in here I feel like
we can like really take this to the next
level and I think that would that we
could maybe even turn it into a video it
may not be the best video I think it's
it would be a room it's pure ease yes
well it's a room that no one else in the
world
I'm sure someone has a home office slash
streaming slash podcast studio okay a
small extra bedroom
there probably are a few people you're
right there's a few no I think I would
really like to redo this room cuz it's
it's probably the ugliest room in the
house it's probably the ugliest room in
the house it's ugly its room in the
house and it's the room that we spend
the most time in man yeah what's up with
that I don't know let's move that junk
stuff into the junk room easy fix
yeah just move the junk ya know I think
that I think that's a good goal I mean
we literally have instead of a shade on
our on our window we have like our well
we have like blinds but there's holes in
them that project onto our green screen
back here so we just tapes we just taped
over the holes like you always hear like
the people you grow blind to things we
can just replace that with like a roll
like like it uh roman shade just boom
there you go I know problem fixed it's
like a it's like a 15 minute fix yeah
but but I it would be fun to do it as a
video do the whole thing thing and it
would be one of those I think the reason
I've been hesitant it's like if we don't
do it for a video I don't think we would
take it as far as I would want to
ideally like cuz I'd like to make it and
it's like this sounds great but it's
like if we're not doing it for video is
it like worth the time cuz we'd only
kind of like halfway do it yeah because
of time restrictions so like I want to
do it for a video but my worry is that
because of the weird setup in here how
would we title it how are the thumbnail
be you know it's like yeah there's our
strange office makeover my strange
addiction but it's like the the after
it'll be like a huge improvement for us
but it's still it's still just a weird
room we have two giant desks a one whole
wall is a green-screen like there's a
bunch of funky lighting in here a bunch
of things on arms we have 1 2 3 mics on
arms 2 lights on arms 1 camera on an arm
there's like mechanical arms everywhere
No
and then 4 monitors on arms there's arms
everywhere like a whole bunch of hard
drives we have multiple uninterruptible
power supplies I mean this is just what
we need yeah because of the stuff that
we need in here it's it's look so good
satisfying after I don't know I don't
think sighs I think that's why we keep
putting it off maybe maybe we just do it
maybe we do it more like a vlog and we
do it on the second channel and edit in
one day okay we just seem to free up
enough time so we can brainstorm this
and really like workshop this and figure
out like maybe even what we do is we
just do one element to it like we build
like Kayla wants make a coffee station
like a tea station in here so maybe we
just like focus on like the T station
build and in addition to that we also do
the whole room strategy that works I
mean I think well really focus on one
thing that's kind of what we did in the
guest room yeah because that's another
weird room it's like what I would do in
our guest room it also has to fit robots
I think it worked and we focused on like
the desk a desk yeah so we can focus on
one one build that might be relatable to
everyone let me put it within the
context of this maybe maybe we'll see
we'll see we obviously need a workshop
this more but guess what time it is
Galen the time for a thing of the week
it's having the thing of the week
I have an admission to make whenever
there's a song thing I just kind of Bob
my head around you wait for my cue to go
the song is done this is not worth
committing defense on my brain it's too
full of knowledge maximal have got backs
all right so my thing of the week this
week is a fast charger a fast USB
charger for all of your devices and it's
uh it has a high power output so I can
even charge my little computer with it
you can charge tablets you can like you
know battery technology has only come so
far so it's not like you can get more
power out of the same volume but
charging technology has come a ways and
you still like you like in order to
charge a battery of the size it used to
take like eight hours to charge it and
then in charge my phone using that same
charger used to take like four hours but
now I can charge the charger in two
hours or three hours and I can charge my
phone in like 60 minutes so it's like I
don't know it's it's a neat upgrade to
something that I already had it's like
the same thing but better but but
charging technology has increased and
I'm I have a new charger and it really
has benefited me because we use our
phones a lot yeah like we use our
hunting law and baby and baby computer
and having a more powerful charging
battery in my like arsenal has been
beneficial already so yeah we got that I
got that for Christmas and it's been a
nice addition to my kit I've been
working on the kit like Ivan maybe
backpack and I have like a little like a
little first-aid kit I like lots of
different cables and Technology I have
like you know some like a like light a
little camera in there I just try I want
to have like one of everything and like
a small of a package as possible and as
multifunction as possible
all about it's coming together it's
coming together um I'm all about being
comfortable so my thing of the week is
some slippers that I got for Christmas
oh I love this story okay so Caleb does
not like spending money I don't like
spending money and this all started a
few years ago I had put some relatively
cheap $17 slippers on my wish list
because I don't like spending money but
I like my feet to be warm you guys know
I'm obsessed with fuzzy socks I'm also
obsessed with slippers and so I put
these slips oh and my adidas let's well
I like those because I can wear comfy
socks and so I put these on my wish list
a few years ago and my mom who's very
much like you know I'm she understands
that I don't want to spend too much
money and you know she got me those
slippers from my Amazon wish list my dad
who's like yeah I think these are better
so I'm not gonna get the ones on her
wish list even though you already got
those I'm just gonna get these ones that
I want to get her so he got me this
other pair of slippers so in one year I
got two pairs of slippers which at the
time felt like overkill so I was like
yeah my slippers
yay other slippers okay cool cool and
the slippers that my mom got me the ones
that I had picked out were great for a
year and then they kind of fell apart
there's seventeen dollar slippers and
the ones my dad got me I actually ended
up wearing for the past few years like
those things many years open up yeah
they've had him for like three years
they're just now starting to get little
holes I know but I'm still wearing them
and um since they started getting holes
in them you know I was like I should put
slippers on my on my wish list I'm gonna
like I'm gonna look up this brand these
ones that have lasted and I'm gonna put
them on my wish list look him up there
$85.00 slippers Kailyn was outraged I
was outraged I called my dad and I was
like what the heck is at $85 on the
slippers for me three years ago how dare
you
the same time I'm so spoiled now I
really like them because they're wool so
they you feet don't get sweaty at all
and like they kind of like mold to your
feet I can wear them with fuzzy socks
they're slip-on so I don't have to use
my hands at all and like they're great
slipper so I was like you know what I'm
gonna put them on my wish list again
this year I'm gonna be I want to treat
myself and my treat myself I mean ask
other people but I was like I'm gonna do
it cuz these are you know they're just
really good slippers and so I you know I
picked one of the designs there's a few
on Amazon and put it on my wish list my
mom being the one that like respects the
wish list got me those ones my dad was
like I found another design I'm gonna
get her these I'm gonna use them but now
I have three pairs of these they will
last for years
so last four years here I'm wearing them
now here's what they do have a
substantial hole substantial yep like
like you you wouldn't really be able to
repair that with some stitching yeah but
anyways the brand is how slinger health
half half link what does have a link in
the show notes yeah they're 100% wool
they're super awesome throw a little
expensive but like even my cheap self
still recommends them cuz they just are
really good well I guys thanks for
joining us in today's Evan and killin
podcast we really enjoy you guys hang
out with us like the POTUS is like a
year old now podcast is a year old
that's weird
we didn't even like acknowledge that
knowledge it cuz we started I mean I
don't the exact date but we started it
like enjoy your birth or to our podcast
this episode 50 so like that makes us
we've skipped a couple for the holidays
oh wow wow that's crazy
alright quick interruption this is post
Evan and Caitlyn podcast chiming back in
we went on a walk and we realized I wait
we forgot
add that announcement and then we
planned we're gonna be moving to a every
other week podcast release schedule for
the majority of our episodes going
forward as part of that like readjusting
the work-life balance thing that we've
been talking about there might still be
like special episodes yeah
we'll throw in like a bonus one every
now and then but we realize as part of
the work-life balance
we just need to so yeah so it's it's an
indefinite a reduction in podcast we
don't you know it could last year it
could last a few months we don't really
know it kind of depends on like how
things go but we wanted to test out at
every other week release schedule and we
thank you guys for understanding well we
tried to balance our lives
okay back to past 7:00 Calum well guys
thanks for sticking with us appreciate
that and you know if you want to show
your support for everything here on
podcast to keep us doing this for for
more time I'm not gonna convince it very
good time go ahead and go over to our
podcast page on iTunes and give us a
five star if you feel like we deserve it
maybe share with a friend a family
member just sure it's random to share it
with someone if they don't also watch
our channel cuz then it's just like
there's two people that talk nonsense
okay share our YouTube channel with them
and say once you get addicted to the
YouTube channel then watch the podcasts
then it'll make sense
yeah two for one in there okay for one
yeah alright guys well I hope you're
having a great day and we'll see you
next time
[Music]